[Music]
Israeli troops ramp up their ground
raids in Gaza this Friday night the air
strikes how Communications been cut off
and the dread of what's
next an excruciating loss I started
making some calls nobody answered one
Calgary man's pain and Agony of losing
loved ones in
Gaza tense times what's the next thing
that's going to happen the small
community is on alert as police try to
track down a suspected mass murderer and
identity under scrutiny the report
challenging singer Buffy St Marie's
indigenous
Roots global national with baren
Asser you're watching what may be the
only broadcast feed coming out of Gaza
tonight most likely being delivered by
satellite as as communication has been
cut off to the strip right now relative
calm outside the Nasser Hospital in
cunis but fears are growing over what
the next 24 hours will
bring good evening there are significant
developments from the Middle East
tonight in the past few hours the
Israeli military has moved closer to a
full-on ground invasion of
Gaza ground forces are expanding their
activity this evening and are ING with
great force on all levels said this
Israeli Army spokesperson this
afternoon around the same time the UN
General Assembly passed a non-binding
resolution calling for a humanitarian
truce with the goal of getting more Aid
in intensified explosions lit up the
night sky in Gaza while internet and
phone Communications appear to be out in
The Enclave isolating millions of
Palestinians from the world and from
each other
Israel is again urging Palestinians to
head to Southern Gaza for their own
safety but that's near impossible with
no fuel and heavy shelling in the region
International journalists haven't been
able to get into Gaza since Israel's war
on Hamas we at Global have been working
with local reporters on the ground to
show you what's happening there Danielle
hamam Jin is in Jerusalem and begins our
coverage tonight first Danielle have we
been able to get in touch with any of
our contacts far practically all means
of communication with Gaza have been cut
off no mobile service no internet we
certainly can't get in touch with local
reporters in Gaza we've been working
with local journalists who have been
risking their lives to get us the
pictures we have been able to show you
now during the past few nights there
were heavy bombardments on Gaza on the
territory but tonight there are a barage
of rockets falling with Israel
announcing ground operations are
expanding is this a full ground Invasion
the next 24 hours will give us the
answer in a briefing an IDF spokesperson
said residents of Gaza City should look
for safer conditions because attacks
would persist but over and over again we
hear gazin say nowhere is safe the IDF
also made reference to alifa hospital
saying Hamas is operating a command and
control center underneath the biggest
Hospital in Gaza there is no way to
verify that claim it is here in chifa
hospital where Hamas operates some of
its command and control cells this is
where the direct rocket attacks command
Hamas forces in a slick presentation the
IDF claimed once again that Hamas is
using the sick and the wounded as human
Shields when medical facilities are used
for Terror purposes they are liable to
lose their protection from attack in
accordance with international law alifa
hospital already inundated and and
critically low on medicine and supplies
continues to receive victims and just
how many people are currently seeking
Refuge there possibly tens of thousands
important to note Farah that Hamas
rocket attacks on Israel have not
stopped during the Israeli bombing
campaign in Gaza when a Hamas rocket hit
a four-story apartment building in Tel
Aviv today Israeli authorities say four
people were injured Farah Danielle Hamin
in Jerusalem thanks for your coverage
now before Israel's operation gaza's
Hamas controlled Health Ministry said
Israeli air strikes have killed more
than 7,000 people in the past 3 weeks
more than 2 million people are inside
the Palestinian enclave and they're
facing conditions that worsen by the day
very few Aid trucks have been allowed in
and the UN is warning that more people
will die soon if nothing is done to
fully open an aid Corridor and as
Redmond Shannon reports a large majority
of UN member States agree
Jihad kafara writes messages of Love on
his wife's shroud and then he does the
same for their stillborn child both
killed in an air strike on Northern
Gaza this is like hirashima says this
man there were 70 or 80 people in this
house kids are in the rubble what have
they done to anyone one Canadian stuck
in Gaza sent us this message on Thursday
night by the minute every night like
literally we we put our heads down not
knowing if we'll ever make it till the
next day um we're always nervous uh the
kids are always nervous and they're very
anxious and very scared for those who
have survived the bombings life is
becoming more difficult by the
hour the United Nations says that Aid
trucks that have been allowed into Gaza
represent 2% of the need what is needed
is Meaningful and
uninterrupted a flow
and to succeed we need an human turn CE
fire to ensure this Aid reaches those in
need with Friday night's bombardment of
Gaza a ceasefire seems a long way off
but simultaneously in New York a
resolution vote at the UN calling for a
truce in Gaza and for the release of
hostages is
adopted it passed by a margin of 120 to
14 Canada among 45 Nations that
abstained there's a lot of work to be
done and I still think that we're a
little bit sort of ragged and everybody
whistling off to Israel to make a visit
as opposed to kind of getting
together finding a collective answer
Canada's un Ambassador Bob Ray abstained
because the resolution did not
specifically condemn hamas's killing of4
1400 Israelis on October 7th the vote is
non-binding but is a strong reminder to
is Israel and Hamas that much of the
world is demanding an immediate
ceasefire Redmond Shannon Global News
London ahud Barack the former prime
minister of Israel was once at the
Forefront of Peace negotiations for the
Middle East our Merced Stevenson spoke
with him earlier today before the
strikes inside Gaza intensified Mercedes
did he give you any insight on the
Strategic issues that Israel is facing
right now well there's so much that
Israel has to think about here Farah
everything from the Tactical on the
ground of of what might succeed to their
domestic politics to their International
reputation and I was curious to hear
from ahud Barack what those issues
they're navigating are and what the
Strategic thinking is as they plan for
this military escalation here's what he
told me the four top factors are
governing Israel's decisions and
behavior going forward there are four
constraints one is the hostages I
mentioned it uh and uh it's very
sensitive issue there is the risk that
it will spread to the north tobah and
Lebanon probably also
Iraqi shite militias backed by Iran from
the Golan to probably some D CS in the
West Bank uh and uh we of course are not
interested but it might happen we should
take it into account third constraint
has to do with the international law we
are committed to the international law
want to minimize the amount of civilians
being hit there and it's a
great heavy constraint and last
constraint is the um need to make sure
we have someone to pass the torch once
we ended the first stage and let's say
within three or six month we end up with
eliminating the military capability of
Kamas and pushing it out of control in
Gaza we not plan to stay there for 10 or
20 years so we have to pass it to
someone else and that's a challenge so
far obviously a lot of things to think
about there as the Israelis make their
plans despite all of the Venom that has
been you know seen on both sides of this
ahud Barack says he still thinks that a
two-state solution is
possible Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
thank you
Mercedes those with relatives in Gaza
are watching the situation with anxious
horror all they can do is hope their
families are safe but as Heather Yorks
West reports a Calgary resident has
received the news he most
feared this was my mom his face pale
with grief Tamar gerada can only stare
at images of what were once loving
parents vibrant sisters all of them
suddenly
gone I saw the the breaking news on
Telegram and um I started making some
calls nobody
answered for weeks from his living room
in Calgary gerada and his wife watched
with horror as Gaza was blanketed with
bombs there had been fear then but also
hope until he confirmed what he'd seen
on telegram I was able to get in touch
with one one of my uh relatives he
pulled my
dad from under dorel
Nasser Dada was 67 his wife Nima Tamar's
beloved mother just 54 they died
alongside 15 other family members
including their daughter nisen who was
set to get married next month and hany a
mother to two children six and 8 years
old the building where my family uh was
in had 35 uh
Apartments where um each apartment had
about 20 people so you do the math it
was a
massacre jata had to use landmarks to
recognize what was once his family's
home on telegram Witnesses say a series
of blasts around 5:00 brought the
building down there were no emergency
workers or special equipment to assist
survivors friends and family could only
help by hand freeing both the
living and the
dead we feel that we were lit down by
the International
Community people are dying every second
in Gaza but as jata moves through his
own blistering sadness he knows so many
other gazin families are grieving too
Heather urix West Global
News on the run for a second day coming
up where police in Maine are focusing
their search for an accused
killer
in the US the man hunt for a mass
shooter has ramped up in Maine days
after he gunned down 18 people in the
city of Leon there are more details
coming out of those lives taken on
Wednesday night at a bowling alley and
at a restaurant among them 36-year-old
Joshua seal who was killed while taking
part in a cornhole tournament for Deaf
athletes a father of four he was a sign
language interpreter for coid 19
government briefings his wife Emily
talked about her grief through sign
language
I'm still processing it still doesn't
feel real the other uh victims and their
families um we going to be connected
forever about this trauma and we'll be
able to support each other in
that in the meantime search efforts are
expanding for the suspect Robert card
police now scouring for The 40-Year-Old
Army reservist by air land and water all
while tensions grip Lewiston and the
surrounding communities our Jackson prco
joins us now from Lewiston Jackson where
does the Manhunt stand right
now well far police just gave an update
and they admit they have no firm leads
as they search for the suspect they're
putting out more information about his
physical characteristics as they also
release more information about the
victims they've identified all 18 of
them the youngest is a 14-year-old
boy police speed away from one search
location out of the Tre and swarm a farm
near the town of Lisbon with guns drawn
they push people back after receiving a
tip linked to the search for suspected
Mass shooter Robert card we were
watching the helicopter and it kept
getting closer and closer and we heard a
gunshot the community is on edge this
Canadian Farm worker says the suspected
gunshot sent him running into a metal
shipping container where he hid with
other employees we actually took cover
for a few minutes and then they pulled
in a few minutes later eventually police
give the all clear and move
on just as they did Thursday night when
a tip brought investigators back to
card's rural home they found a note from
the suspect but no sign of him there's
no question in my mind uh that we will
bring this individual into custody one
way or the other police say they're
focused on several search locations
including a river where divers are
scouring the water I think that uh every
minute that this goes on uh we're more
and more concerned uh you know because
the what's the next thing that's going
to happen
yet questions linger about whether card
with his history of mental health
problems and previous threats of gun
violence should have had access to
weapons in the first place and it
happened he went and did what he said he
was going to do it doesn't make any
sense why that wasn't addressed before
the fact that it was actually capable of
happening tonight local police are
lifting the stay-at-home order despite
no firm leads on the suspect but that is
a huge relief to this community which
has been locked down for days one of the
impacts of that Farah is that the
community has not been able to come
together and grieve and mourn or hold
any kind of vigil local organizers tell
us that Sunday night they are planning a
community rally to come together and try
and bring things together after this
awful
tragedy the Trudeau government's
decision to put a three-year pause on
the federal fuel sirar charge for home
heating oil is provoking political
backlash the conservative opposition is
accusing the Liberals of trying to save
plummeting support in Atlantic Canada
while some Premier outside that region
are asking why their residents aren't
getting a tax break David Aken
reports it is an extraordinary team I
have behind me it was the Atlantic
Canadian MPS behind the Prime Minister
who had been pushing for the so-called
pause on the home heating oil carbon
tax nearly one in three Atlantic
Canadians use oil to heat their homes
and multiple polls have shown that that
carbon tax was putting their political
Fortunes in
Peril opposition leader Pierre pev who
was an Atlantic candidate himself this
week said the Prime Minister was
abandoning his core climate policy
because of those plunging polls Justin
Trudeau is in
total panic mode but the PM dismissed
the idea political pressure forced the
tax pause we are doubling down on uh our
uh fight against climate change and
keeping true to the principles that we
are supporting Canadians while we fight
climate change KV wasn't buying it
because he's making political
calculations this is not about
environmental science it's about
political science the decision to cut
taxes on home heating oil also provoke
strong reaction outside Atlantic Canada
where natural gas is most commonly used
to heat homes on social media Alberta's
Danielle Smith said I am frankly
Disturbed that the same break will not
be extended to albertans and those from
Saskatchewan and elsewhere in Canada who
Heat their homes with natural gas
similar comments were made by
Saskatchewan Scott Mo and Ontario's Doug
Ford environmental Advocates expressed
disappointment with the pause they have
long argued that raising the price of
carbon is the most efficient way to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions and they
worry that the Trudeau government's
decision to back off that principle for
political reasons or whatever will make
it more difficult for Canada to meet its
climate change commitments far David
Aken in Ottawa thanks
David and while Taylor Swift seems to be
just about everywhere these days you
might not expect to see her face on a
giant pumpkin but that's what Ohio based
artist Janette Paras created she painted
this 180 kgam or nearly 400 lb pumpkin
to look like the mega star it's been
dubbed Taylor Swift That's gal National
for Friday night good
[Music]
night